what I think we see sometimes in
politics is where we they push
politicians who are unhealthy to
continue running and continue their role
because there's a lot of people attached
to them and I think we saw that in the
case with I don't know exactly what's
going on with Dianne Feinstein but she
has shingles and she probably should
have retired a long time ago Joe Biden
doesn't seem totally competent John
fetterman probably didn't need to finish
running that campaign after he had the
stroke but it seemed that he was
pressured by his wife and others um
Chrissy what do you think about this
stuff yeah it's just I was thinking that
the whole Biden thing is so reminiscent
of what's going on with John fetterman I
just I genuinely know talking about this
with Ashley the other day too like
there's no way that man just has
depression there has to be something
else he's got to be covering up for
something else
um but at the same time you know I
counter or counteract myself because I'm
like there's no way his wife just left a
man that could be dying of something to
go to Canada unless she's like a
Stepford Wife